it's a bird it's a plane it's gone just
seven weeks ago Henry Cavill posted the
news on his Instagram the fans have been
waiting for ever since Zack Snyder's
Justice League his long-awaited return a
Superman sent fans into a frenzy as they
looked forward to his continuation of
the character the celebration was
short-lived however with the news
breaking on Wednesday that Henry Cavill
was now out to Superman and his role in
the DC Universe had come to an end
he won't let me live James Gunn and the
CEO of DC Studios Peter Safran have
spent the last few weeks hold up and
hidden away while they developed what
comes next for DC and fans have
questions regarding who if anyone from
the snyderverse will be making the jump
to the new universe about to take shape
given his most recent announcement he
would be forgiven if you thought cavall
was unlocked to stay in the role
unfortunately Gunn and saffron of
different plans with the director
announcing on Twitter that they're going
their younger route for the Kryptonian
meaning caval is out the actor also
announces departure from the role in his
own Instagram post expressing his
sadness but also reminding fans that
Superman still lives unsurprisingly the
internet went Ablaze with fans
expressing their displeasure with the
decision to remove the British actor
when they just got him back if you're
feeling betrayed angry upset depressed
or simply dumbfounded you aren't alone
social media has a whole host of people
ready to join you Superman is dead
we all wish you weren't the snide of us
isn't known for a deep roster of great
films but there are some bright spots
within them and Henry Cavill was one of
them although his darker portrayal of
the character was divisive He was
largely beloved by the fan base his
dismissal from Superman brought on many
negative takes including one poster who
wrote I could not be more devastated in
one move you have single-handedly
destroyed every ounce of interest and
enthusiasm I had for DC movies another
person agreed with the sentiment saying
this legit makes no sense someone else
eloquently let James goon know what it
felt like when they read the news
writing easily the swiftest most precise
kick to the Bulls I think anyone has
done with all of Superman's power in all
of DC history of course Twitter isn't
the only Outlet where fans reacted to
the news many also took to Reddit to
talk about the Revelation that their
favorite Superman actor isn't returning
one redditor took a different path and
thought about how kavel himself must be
feeling wow that just sucks I hope we
can catch a break soon someone send him
some Warhammer figures to paint finally
there was one user who wasn't quite as
negative expressing a little interest in
what's next interested to see where
James Gunn takes to DCU but definitely
would have loved to have seen more of
Henry a Superman sucks we don't get to
see him as geralt anymore either
hopefully he lands another iconic role
in the near future this brings up a good
point with all the news about Gunn's New
Direction there are many many questions
about where he's headed consider this
Mercy it shouldn't be surprising that
James Gunn and Peter saffron a cleaning
house at DC while Disney and Marvel have
been doing what Warner Brothers and DC
have been trying to do for a decade DC
is failing where Marvel is succeeding
even without their most well-known
characters Spider-Man the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four Marvel was able to build
a universe at James Cinema all the while
DC has taken three of the most globally
well-known characters of all time
Superman Batman and Wonder Woman and
mostly stumbled in its real percent
handling of them with the announcement
that new leadership is in store for the
DC movies ushering a new universe with
fresh takes and rebooted storylines
seems to be a solid Choice the problem
is the backlash from a fan base that
wants to see all the aspects they love
about the snyderverse of course this
also raises more questions about the
characters we have yet to hear about
what will happen with Jason Momoa after
the release of Aquaman 2. what about
Zachary Levi Dwayne Johnson is there any
point in The Flash movie now some of
them Express their love and support for
Henry Cavill with Momoa commenting on
his Instagram post love you brother
along with heart emojis Levi commented
hope to catch you in another Universe
sir there's no question that the tide is
Shifting and it looks like gun and
saffron are ditching anything that
contains the baggage of the past as they
move forward fans have a lot to get over
and gun has to bring something
Monumental to help that along
foreign